. Wir haben auch schon lange nicht mehr, ne? Wir haben sehr lange nicht mehr gemacht. Wir haben schon viele Insider-Gags und Jokes und so, dass wir die gar nicht mehr alle benutzen müssen, ne? Das ist doch geil. Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Podcast du Ufo. Endlich mal wieder eine Anmoderation. Ich hab sie so vermisst, endlich mal wieder eine Anmoderation aus dem Bund. Weißt du, was ich heute eigentlich sagen wollte? Ich wollte heute eigentlich sagen, Tietze, ich wollte heute eigentlich sagen, herzlichen Glückwunsch zur Wahl des Podcast-Ufos. Einfach mal um so ein bisschen direkt so eine höhere Messlatte zu setzen. Herzlichen Glückwunsch zur Wahl dieses Podcasts. Gute Wahl. Wir sind noch online und man weiss ja auch nicht, wann man diesen Podcast jetzt hört. Man könnte ihn ja in zehn Jahren hören. Ich habe mir tatsächlich heute... Ich glaube nämlich nicht. Ich glaube nämlich nicht, weil ich glaube, es sei unsere Seite zusammengebrochen. Die hat nämlich nicht so viel Speicherplatz, wie du, glaube ich, immer behauptest, dass sie hat. Ich glaube, ab Folge 50 sind die ersten Folgen einfach weg. Und hast du die irgendwie zwischengespeichert oder so? Hast du die irgendwo noch in einem Archiv? Ist irgendwo auf den niederländischen Antillen oder haben wir da irgendwo so ein Archiv, wo wir die ganzen Dinge aufgespart haben oder nicht? Ne, gar nichts, aber ich habe tatsächlich heute ein Paket erreicht aus Amerika, hat mich erreicht, ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt, tut mir leid, ich kann zwar so ein bisschen unterzukommen, mich hat ein Paket erreicht und zwar von einem meiner Lieblingspodcasts What the Fuck with Mark Maron, wo es glaube ich um die 600 Folgen gibt, wo aber nur so die letzten 200 auf iTunes online sind. Und die ersten kann man gar nicht mehr bekommen, sondern nur auf einer kaufbaren DVD, wo die ersten 100 Folgen auf zwei DVDs draussen sind. Die habe ich mir tatsächlich bestellt. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie ich mir die anhören soll, ehrlich gesagt. Weil die sind jetzt keine Podcasts, sondern so auf CD, und dann muss man sie aber anhören. Ein Discman. Dann merkt er sich nicht, wo sie sind, aber die sind auch scheiße eigentlich. Und ich weiss, sind es DVDs oder CDs, weil DVDs hören können die ja gar nicht abspielen. DVDs, ja, weiß ich nicht. Gibt es auch walkbare DVD-Player eigentlich? Ja, fürs Auto gibt es die. Auf jeden Fall gibt es es. Ich habe das aber nur komischerweise, wenn ich mir das vorstelle, wie das Ding aussieht, und ich weiss, dass es gibt, aber ich habe nur ein Bild davon und immer läuft Spongebob darauf. Immer läuft, es sind so kleine, kleine Bildschirme, wo man eine DVD reinstecken kann und in meinem Gehirn läuft da immer Spongebob drauf, weil immer wenn ich diese Dinger sehe, haben Kinder das. Und damals gab es irgendwie nur die Spongebob-DVD dafür. Ah ja, du meinst doch hier, wo dann auf der Hinterseite von dem Sitz dann nochmal so ein Monitor ist. Ja genau, aber das gibt es halt auch tragbar. Aber warum hat sich das nicht durchgesetzt? Mittlerweile müssen die doch echt günstig sein und die lieben Opel Passaten. Ich glaube, die waren wahnsinnig dick, weil die halt das Laufwerk brauchten und da hat man einfach direkt auch einen Laptop nehmen können. Ich glaube, das war einfach, ich glaube, das hat nie irgendwie gefruchtet. Und es ist, glaube ich, auch die falsche Verkaufsstrategie, weil Autos kaufen ja in der Regel erwachsene Menschen und wenn jetzt der Autoverkauf fragt, hey, wollen Sie, dass Ihre Kinder auch noch die ganze Zeit Fernsehen schauen? Naja, aber das ist ja auch so, dass Kinder ja die Eltern auch wahnsinnig beeinflussen durch Quängeleien. Deswegen gibt es ja in Supermärkten zum Beispiel auch am Ende auch immer diese Stände, wo Kinder dann quengeln können, diese Quängeleien. Aber nicht beim Autokauf. Naja, kleine Autos stehen am Ausgang, kleine Rausgehautos, Quengelautos. Man muss ja auch sagen, dass Autofahren extrem wenig Spaß macht, bis man vorne sitzen darf. Das ist ja tatsächlich dann der Punkt, wo man sich denkt, Alter, what? Wie geil ist das denn? Die Welt bewegt sich um mich herum und davor war es immer so, ja. Davor saß man immer hinten und dann wurden die Fenster abgeschäumt mit diesen grossen Noppen und diese Sonnenschutzdinger, die man hinten immer drin hat und so grosse Stefan-on-Tour-Aufkleber auf der Seite, wo man gar nicht mehr richtig rausgucken konnte. Ich sass ja immer falschrum. Ja, das denke ich mir schon länger, dass du falschrum sitzt in deinem Leben. Habe ich dir schon mal erzählt mit der U-Bahn? Nee. Ich weiß nicht, jetzt musst du mir wirklich mal helfen, ob ich das schon erzählt habe mit der U-Bahn. Ich glaube schon. Ich werde das Gegenteil sagen von dem, was es eigentlich ist. Und zwar, hier sassen wir in der U-Bahn und mir gegenüber sassen ein alter Mann, ein Opa mit seinem Enkel. Und dann hat der Opa war anscheinend gerade dabei, dem Enkel die Welt zu erklären. Also er war gerade mittendrin, glaube ich, so 30 Prozent hat er gerade durch. Und er war gerade angekommen beim Thema U-Bahn-Sitze. Und anscheinend sind sie zu dem Zweck U-Bahn gefahren, damit der Opa alles, was er über U-Bahn-Sitze weiß, dem Enkel jetzt sagen kann. Weil irgendwann ist man auch in einem Alter, wo man das auch vertragen kann. Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, man kann sich ja in Fahrtrichtung oder gegen die Fahrtrichtung setzen. Die meisten Menschen setzen sich lieber in Fahrtrichtung, weil sie damit besser klarkommen. Dann gibt es noch eine große Gruppe von Leuten, denen ist es relativ egal, ob sie in Fahrtrichtung oder gegen Fahrtrichtung sitzen. Und dann gibt es noch eine sehr kleine Gruppe an Menschen, die können nur gegen die Fahrtrichtung sitzen. Und der Junge, okay, alles klar, habe ich verstanden. Und ich dachte mir, Moment mal, also du wirkst schon wie ein sehr gut informierter Mann, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Aber wo kommt diese Statistik jetzt plötzlich her? So ein Meister-Joda-Typ. Ja, die würde man ja nie hinterfragen. Und ich habe auch sofort gedacht, oh geil, interessant. Aber wo kommt diese Statistik? Wo niemand Zwischenfragen stellen würde? Nee, nie. Und wenn man mal eine Zwischenfrage stellt, bricht das sofort in sich zusammen, dieses Modell. Sofort. Ja, aber auch mit so einer statistischen Gewissheit. Es gibt noch eine ganz kleine Gruppe von Menschen. Aber ich denke mir dann auch immer, die Leute sollen sich einfach nicht anstellen. Also ich habe das Problem nicht, mir ist es völlig egal. Ich kann auch manchmal, ich kann auch kopfüber in der U-Bahn fahren, ist mir völlig egal. Und dann sitze ich in so einem Viererbereich und habe mich da so hingesetzt, damit ich vorne die Beine ausstrecken kann. Und dann sind theoretisch vor mir noch Plätze frei und neben mir. So, und dann sitze ich in Fahrtrichtung und jemand setzt sich neben mich, obwohl die beiden Plätze vor mir frei wären. Und es wäre eigentlich sozial akzeptierter, wenn man sich den Platz neben mir freilassen würde. Aber dann setzt sich da halt irgendwer hin, der nur in Fahrtrichtung sitzen kann, und dann setze ich mich demonstrativ wieder weg von dem auf die beiden leeren Plätze in Gegenfahrtrichtung. Das ist mir immer ein bisschen unangenehm, weil ich mich ja dann von dem Menschen, der sich gerade neben mich gesetzt hat, wegsetze. Aber bist du denn Vertreter der Diagonaltaktik? Klar, sofort. Ja, natürlich, die Diagonaltaktik, also einer links unten, der andere rechts oben, damit beide Beinfreiheit hat. Alles andere ist mega awkward bei mir, weil ich bin so gross, dass meine Beine immer so in den Beinen des anderen hängen würden. Du hast ja noch Beine, oder? Meine Knie, ich habe wahnsinnig lange Beine, meine Knie hängen immer quasi auf dem Sitz des anderen schon. Ja, weil der Junge mit seinem Opa, da hatte sowohl der Junge als auch der Opa keine Beine mehr, deswegen war das weniger ein Problem. Schön, dass wir diese Richtung einschlagen, direkt zu Beginn. Ich wollte mal kurz fragen, du bist ja auch so ein Twitter-Experte, kann ich folgenden Tweet raushauen? Nee. Achtung. Mit dem Todesstern? Wow! Unfassbar geiles Todesstern-Tattoo, was sie da haben. Nee, ich habe Hautkrebs. Kann man das raushauen, oder ist das schon zu weit? Werden dann die Hater kommen? Ist das so ein Tweet, der quasi, sagen wir mal, in der Welt der Fliegen die Scheisse ist, wo sehr viele Hater drauf fliegen direkt.
Ja, ich finde ihn jetzt gar nicht so gut. Die Hater, glaube ich, würden schon ein bisschen kommen, aber ich weiß nicht, gibt es nicht noch eine Variante, wo man verbinden kann,
die Star Wars Metapher? Darum ging es mir jetzt gar nicht. Mir ging es mehr, ich wurde mal Hautkrebs
in einem Tweet verbinden. Ach so, okay. Ja, ist okay, aber wird natürlich den ein oder anderen,
dass die ein oder andere Augenbraue nach oben katapultieren, da werde ich da, glaube ich mal. Ja, okay, kein Problem. Du, wir wollten ja heute über folgendes Thema reden. Es bewegt uns alle und ich denke mal, vielleicht können wir heute so ein kleines Experiment machen und mit euch mal sozusagen auditiv durch dieses Thema wandeln. Und zwar haben wir uns vorgeschlagen, haben wir uns gedacht, wir machen ein Thema, was uns alle berührt, wo wir sehr oft sind, wo wir eigentlich alle mal drüber reden sollten, aber es eigentlich noch nie getan haben. Ganz kurz eine Sache dazwischen. Ja, okay. Ich habe damit überhaupt nichts zu tun mit dem, was jetzt kommt. Und weiter. Da hast du den Spieß umgedreht. Sonst distanziere ich mich mal von den Themen, aber okay. Und zwar wollen wir heute reden über... Ganz kurz, bevor du deine Geschichte weitererzählst, kannst du vielleicht... Ich will dich nicht unterbrechen, aber kannst du vielleicht eine andere oder bessere Geschichte erzählen? Das war keine Geschichte, ich wollte einfach nur das zum Thema hinleiten. Ach so, okay, kannst du vielleicht ein besseres Thema machen an der Stelle? Also ich will dich jetzt nicht unterbrechen oder so, aber geht es einfach noch ein bisschen besser? Ich würde gerne über Supermärkte sprechen und Florentin hat das Thema für sehr gut befunden. Ich habe danach auch gesagt, wir können auch über Philosophie reden und über ein anderes cooleres Thema. Aber du warst anscheinend so angetan vom Supermärkte-Thema. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was für Geschichten da ich komme. Also ich hätte nicht gesagt, ich hätte mit der Reaktion auf den Vorschlag Supermärkte, der mir gerade so kam, weil ich im Supermarkt war oder so, da kam so eine enorme Rückmeldung von dir, sofort so ein Ja, so ein euphorisches Ja, was ich noch nie erlebt habe. Also ich bin sehr gespannt, was gleich kommt. Mal gerade, Schnitt, wie es passiert ist im Messenger, einfach machen wir das Thema Ja, einfach Ja. Ja, aber da siehst du mal, was ich gewohnt bin von dir. Das euphorische Ja. Ich bin sonst gar keine Reaktion von dir gewohnt. Dieses Ja habe ich so in Erinnerung wie so ein herausschreiendes, wie so ein auf der Stelle springendes Ja! Ja, ich liebe ja tatsächlich Supermärkte. Supermärkte sind ein wichtiger Teil meiner Persönlichkeit. Ich liebe es, einkaufen zu gehen. Ich gehe auch fast jeden Tag einkaufen und es gibt ja so einen großen Supermarkt in meiner Nähe, der ist zweistöckig. Na, das hat viele Gründe. Also erst mal, ich mag es generell, in Räumen zu sein, wo ich mir potenziell alles kaufen kann. Naja. In Supermärkten gibt es selten so teure Dinge, dass man sie sich nicht leisten kann. Und das ist schon mal ein geiles Gefühl. Du gehst in den Raum und du weisst, ich kann mir hier alles kaufen. Alles, was du dir anschaust, kannst du potenziell besitzen, egal was es ist. Und diese unglaubliche Auswahlmöglichkeit. Und dann bin ich da zum Beispiel, also mein Lieblingssupermarkt, sag ich jetzt gleich mal, ist Hit. Hit. Hit. Ja, hab ich schon nie gehört. Ist sehr selten, gibt es nicht überall. Aber es gibt auch Norma. Es gibt auch Norma, richtig.
Norma.
Es gibt einmal in meiner Nähe, und der ist echt genial, der ist erstens zweistöckig, was schon mal finde ich super fancy.
Ist schon geil, ist schon super geil.
Ja, vor allem, du hast dann wie auf dem Flughafen so Laufbänder, allerdings hast du ja natürlich auch immer im Supermarkt das grosse Thema Einkaufswägen am Start. Das heißt, du hast gleich nochmal so eine Abenteuerfahrt mit eingebaut. Aber Moment mal kurz, wie kommst du denn hoch jetzt? Ja, auch mit einem Laufband. Mit einem Laufband. Also diese geraden Laufbänder, die hochgehen. Ja, genau. Das ist ja Wahnsinn. Das ist ja der Wahnsinn. Das ist unglaublich. Und man kann immer tatsächlich schön den Unterschied zwischen Erwachsenen und Kindern sehen. Und zwar Erwachsene laufen immer langweilig die richtige Laufbahn runter und Kinder fast immer die falsche. Also so, dass sie gegen die Laufbahn laufen und laufen dann so die Laufbahn hoch. Und es ist wirklich so der Unterschied, wo man sieht, okay, der Erwachsene, langweilig, boring, folgt die Regeln. Pragmatisch. Die Kinder immer direkt brechen, immer alles sofort brechen, sofort, ah, das gehört linksrum, ich mach's rechtsrum. Aber da müssen wir kurz nochmal drüber sprechen, diese Laufbänder, die gibt es ja auch an Flughäfen, da sind die ja gerade meistens. Also wirklich, die transportieren dann nur einfach über lange, lange, gerade Strecken, einfach geradeaus, damit man schneller ist, von Gate zu Gate. Geht man, geht man darauf oder steht man darauf? Meine Interpretation ist ganz klar, man geht darauf. Die Dinge sind dazu da, wenn sie nicht wären, würdest du auch gehen, du bist einfach nur schneller. Definitiv man steht, ganz klar. Ich bin da ganz klar, Fraktion stehen und auch bei den gewinkelten Laufbänden im Supermarkt, einfach stehen bleiben. Du laufst und bleibst stehen, weil warum solltest du dann mehr Kraft aufwenden, als nötig ist? Und dann auch noch genau in der Mitte stehen bleiben, als alle Leute, die es vielleicht anders interpretieren könnten, weil sie vielleicht schneller los müssen oder so, einfach generell den Weg versparen. Ja, aber das verstehst du, der Supermarkt ist eine Oase der Gemütlichkeit. Da gibt es keinen schnell, ich will noch kurz vor Ladenschluss mir eine Packung Mehl kaufen, weil ich Stress auf der Arbeit hatte und meine Frau zu Hause sich aufregt. Nee, das ist einfach mal ein bisschen chillaxen, sich ein bisschen exotische Früchte anschauen, mal irgendwie an Gewürzen riechen. Das ist so eine Feel-Good-Oase, dafür ist so ein Supermarkt da. Ist dir mal aufgefallen, dass im Supermarkt zum Beispiel immer sehr, sehr ruhige Musik läuft? Und wenn du mal irgendwie so Klamotten einkaufen gehst, da ist ja manchmal, liegt da so ein DJ nebenbei aus und es ist die ganze Zeit so
Wenn das im Supermarkt laufen würde,
die ganze Zeit so eine mega aufregende
Du hast gerade wirklich Musik imitiert, wie ein 80-jähriger Mann.
Was die Kinder heutzutage hören,
puff, puff, puff,
wirklich als wie jemand, der in seinem Leben noch nicht Musik gehört hätte.
Das war schon mal, als ich gesagt habe,
ins Internet reinstellen.
Ich habe manchmal so, ich weiß auch nicht,
ich hänge einfach sehr gerne mit sehr alten Menschen ab.
Und immer noch ein paar Sachen hängen bleibt, mein Gott, dass es immer so an Pranger stellen muss. Aber wenn im Supermarkt, ich finde das eine sehr lustige Vorstellung, wenn im Supermarkt plötzlich so eine sehr, sehr aufregende Technomusik laufen würde, dann wäre gleich eine ganz andere Stimmung so. Aber es ist natürlich immer so eine sehr wohlfühlig Musik am Start oder halt Lokalradio. Die beste Musik von heute. Ja, das stimmt, aber das gehört einfach dazu. Ich finde, da kriegt man das auch mit. Es ist der einzige Ort, an dem ich überhaupt noch Radio höre, von daher ist das in Ordnung. Aber also, was ich immer so geil finde, ist, wenn es wahnsinnig viel Auswahl gibt. Zum Beispiel in meinem, also der absolute beste Supermarkt aller Zeiten ist in meiner Heimatstadt, aber das ist ja egal. Da gab es auf jeden Fall einen, es war ein Edeka, es war ein Edeka, der Hit ist jetzt in Berlin. Aber es gibt auch Norma. Es gibt auch Norma, genau. Und da gab es zum Beispiel ein ganzes Regal für Senf. Ein ganzes Regal, so vier, fünf Meter, nur für Senf. Und man denkt sich, okay, geil, schaue ich mir mal an, da gibt es wahnsinnig viele verschiedene Senfsorten natürlich. Aber dann fragt man sich, okay, es gibt so die klassischen Klassiker, irgendwie so Dewelei, irgendwie hier Kraft, die ganzen Klassiker, Norma. Dijon, ja diese ganzen, aber dann guckt man weiter nach rechts in dem Regal und man findet so diese ganz kleinen, fast schon handwerklichen Senfgläser irgendwie, die irgendwo in Schuppen irgendwo von so einem Hobby-Senfer hergestellt wurden. Und man denkt sich immer, okay, da hängt ja wahnsinnig viel dran an so einem Glas Senf. Das muss ja irgendwo hergestellt worden sein, das muss irgendwo abgefüllt worden sein. Wird jetzt in derselben Fabrik abgefüllt wie der Dewelein? Das ist ein sehr guter Gedanke. Das ist ein sehr guter Gedanke. Das ist ein sehr guter Instrumentmarkt, das muss irgendwo hergestellt worden sein. Ja, absolut. Dieses Ding muss irgendwo irgendwer gemacht haben. Sehr guter Gedanke, Florian. Vielen Dank. Da gibt es 50 verschiedene Senfsorten, die ja alle in Konkurrenz zueinander stehen. Das heißt, sie werden wahrscheinlich auch andere Fabriken benutzen. Ich würde jetzt wahnsinnig sein. Es gibt in Deutschland 50 verschiedene Firmen, wo stehen diese ganzen Häuser, in denen Senf abgefüllt wird. Das muss ja unglaublich viele sein. Das muss ja auch in der Nähe sein. Da gibt es ja nicht nur eins in Deutschland, sondern damit sich das lohnt, damit man nicht ewig weit fahren muss. Wo sind die alle? Aber das ist ja das Geile an Deutschland. Das ist ja für jedes Produkt. Das ist ja das total Geile an Deutschland, wenn du rumgehst und fragst, was haben deine Eltern für Berufe, sind das ja meistens so ganz komische Mittelstandsberufe, irgendwie, ja, wir machen Senf oder so, also ich höre immer nur ganz komische Dinge,
wo man nicht im Traum daran denkt, also in meinem Freundeskreis sagen alle,
die Eltern sind arbeitslos, weil ich mir ganz komisch,
aber das ist halt so, die Eltern denken dann
immer, also die Eltern arbeiten dann immer in so Dingen,
die man nie in Betracht zieht.
Also zum Beispiel, also meine Mutter zum Beispiel, die arbeitet in einer Firma,
die stellen diese Sprühdinger
her, von zum Beispiel
Haarspray oder Seife. Also diese Kappen, diese Kappen, diese Vorrichtungen, diese Pumpvorrichtungen stellen die her. Und man denkt ja nie daran, dass Firmen das machen, aber irgendwelche Firmen machen alles. Also alles macht irgendwer, alles kommt irgendwo her. Ja, aber machen die dann alle? Also es gibt ja verschiedene Dosenformen und verschiedene Funktionen. Nein, es gibt einen riesen krassen Konkurrenzmarkt, die nur halt diese Sprühvorrichtungen erstellen. Ja, aber das ist ja immer das Interessante, dass es das ja eben nicht nur einmal gibt. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass wenn man halt wie so bei Age of Empires, so du hast ein Gebäude für Käse, ein Gebäude für Fleisch, ein Gebäude für Schafe und irgendwann hast du halt alle Gebäude, die es gibt, die man bauen kann und dann war es das so. Aber in der echten Welt ist das ja nicht so. Also da es ja nur für Käse, gibt es ja für das Glas, gibt es ein Beispiel dafür, dass sie gepumpt werden und für unfassbar viele. Und dann ist ja die Map nicht begrenzt groß, sondern dann gibt es das Ganze nochmal in Thüringen und das Ganze gibt es nochmal in Brandenburg und dann gibt es nochmal in Norma. Andere Maps. Dann gibt es dann alles nochmal und nochmal andere Maps. Die Schneemap und dann gibt es noch die Lava-Map und dann die Regenwald-Map und überall gibt es diese
Käsehäuser, aber halt
hundert davon. Das ist ja unglaublich.
Das ist ja auch ein gutes Beispiel. Ich finde,
Age of Empires ist ja quasi die echte Welt,
nur in sehr stark vereinfacht runtergebrochen.
Und quasi gibt es davon alles viel
komplexer und viel grösser. Aber ich weiß nicht, wie es geht,
aber ich würde wahnsinnig werden, wenn ich von
Regal mit Senfsorten,
wenn es fünf, lass es fünf Senfsorten sein, die es gibt, ich würde wahnsinnig werden. Ich stehe da bestimmt, ich schwöre dir eine halbe Stunde, das ist nicht gelogen, ich stehe da eine halbe Stunde vor und kann mich nicht entscheiden. Absolut, geht mir ganz genauso, aber ich geniesse das, ich finde das total geil. Ich hasse das, ich gehe wahnsinnig. Und dann denke ich mir auch, dann kaufe ich mal Senf, den ich eigentlich nicht kaufen wollte, also dann irgendwie neue Sachen ausdrucken, so konterintuitiv rangehen. Und vor allem, dann schaust du dir mal so einen ländlichen
Senf an, irgendwie Hubers Senf, und dann
ist da ein Gewinnspiel drauf.
Da ist da ein Gewinnspiel, schicken sie uns bis zum
so und so vielsten irgendwas ein, und dann denkst du,
da gibt es bei Hubers, gibt es dann auch noch eine
Marketingabteilung in dem Senfhaus.
Ja, es gibt Hubers, es gibt aber auch Norma.
Gerechtig, da gibt es dann auch noch zwei Leute,
die sich irgendwie so ein Gewinnspiel ausdenken,
und wie viele Leute schicken da was ein?
Ich habe letztens, ich war im Zug unterwegs
und da gab es das Raps-Magazin,
... Gerechtig, da gibt es dann auch noch zwei Leute, die sich irgendwie so ein Gewinnspiel ausdenken. Und wie viele Leute schicken da was ein? Ich habe letztens, ich war im Zug unterwegs und da gab es das Rapsmagazin, wo alles über Raps drin stand, einfach die Rapsbibel, habe ich natürlich verschlungen. Und auch da gab es ein Gewinnspiel für den Rapskönig und der Hauptpreis war, man konnte die Rapskönigin besuchen. Und ich mir auch dachte, das ist ja nochmal eine neue Welt, jetzt hat auch noch alles eine Königin, jetzt gibt es noch eine Senfkönigin. Was macht man da mit der, also worüber redet man mit der Senfkönigin? Ja, ist eine gute Frage. Was wäre so ein typischer Satz, Einstiegssatz, du begegnest der Senfkönigin zum ersten Mal? Du bist wahnsinnig aufgeregt, weil das ist die fucking Senfkönigin. Auf ihrem Hermelin, eure Majestät. Nein, war nur ein Scherz. Ich würde fragen, wie kriegt man Senfflecken am besten raus? Das sind so diese Fragen, die mich umtreiben dann. Ja, und da gab es dann auch ein Interview mit der Rapskönigin, also dieses Interview war unglaublich, das war gepackt voller wirklich tiefen Eindrücke in die Rapswelt und so, ja, was muss eine gute Rapskönigin denn können und hier und da und das war unglaublich. Und auch da ein Gewinnspiel, wo ich mir dachte, es muss doch, es gibt so viele Gewinnspiele, dass es doch bestimmt auch ein paar Gewinnspiele gibt, wo einfach niemand teilnimmt. Niemand. Da sitzt dann in Huber Senfrührerei, sitzen dann irgendwie zwei Leute und machen ein Gewinnspiel und da kommt einfach nichts zurück und denkt sich der Marketingtyp, ja, jetzt habe ich Marketing studiert. Das sind auch meistens die schlechten Preise, wie zum Beispiel den Besuch, wobei Besuch einer Senfkündigin, ein Treffen ist schon sehr geil. Da werden sehr viele mitgemacht haben. Ich fand das so gut, ey, ohne Witz. Vor allem, es waren ja zwei Karten, ne, und die Vorstellung, man geht zu einem Freund hin und sagt, Alter, ich habe bei einem Gewinnsspiel gewonnen. Und er, wow, wie geil, ich habe zwei Karten, Alter, wie geil, und ich will, dass du mitkommst, Alter, wie geil, dankeschön, zur fucking Rapskönigin. Was? Nein, also die Leute, die ich kenne, würden ausrasten vor Freude. Ja, manche würden da ausrasten, andere nicht. So ist es, naja, so gibt die und die Menschen. Aber tatsächlich, das ist natürlich
auch ein Angebot, wo ich nicht ablehnen könnte,
Rapskönigin. Wollen wir jetzt mal
quasi den
Supermarktgang mit unseren
Hörern zusammen bestreiten?
Also ungefähr ist ja ungefähr jeder
Supermarkt ist ja gleich aufgebaut, also zumindest
die Reihenfolge der Waren, wie sie
auftauchen, ist ja meistens gleich.
Wollen wir das mal machen?
Okay. Okay, also wir kommen in den Supermarkt
rein, den klassischen Supermarkt. Holst du
Vielen Dank. Die Reihenfolge der Waren, wie sie auftauchen, ist ja meistens gleich. Wollen wir das mal machen? Okay. Okay, also wir kommen in den Supermarkt rein, den klassischen Supermarkt. Holst du dir einen Wagen oder nicht? Nee, ich habe einen Jutebeutel. Holst du dir so einen Tragekorb? Nee, auch nicht. Die sind mir suspekt. Die sind meistens kaputt. Das ist aber eigentlich nicht erlaubt, seine eigenen Tragegestelle mit reinzubringen. Nee, das ist auch für nachher.
Nein, also mein Tragebeutel ist nur für nachher zum Ausgehen.
Und im Supermarkt würde ich ganz viele Waren ganz umständlich auf der Hand balancieren.
Das ist so mein Ding.
Aber nur auf der Hand, also nicht auf dem Arm oder so, nur auf der Hand.
Doch, das T-Shirt nehme ich ja manchmal so als Tuch und mache da alles rein.
Also ich bin da sehr umständlich.
Du bist ein Korbtyp, ne?
Ich bin so ein Korbtyp, ich ziehe den dann so hinter mir her und dann lasse ich da so Dinge reinfallen. Das ist so meine Strategie. Oder wenn du mit anderen Freunden unterwegs bist, nimmst du dann einen Wagen und dann springst du vorne rein und dann geht's los und dann geht die Runde Fahrt. Oder man tritt halt so ein paar Sachen vor sich her, so wie so ein Fussball einfach so. Das wird dann immer mehr irgendwie und es wird immer anstrengender, aber man kommt schon ganz gut durch. Und die Milch läuft halt aus, manchmal auf dem Boden. Ja, ja, gut, aber das ist ja in Ordnung. Aber hier fängt das ja schon an. Also Supermärkte... Stopp, stopp! Okay, Entschuldigung. Hast du im Supermarkt schon mal was runtergeschmissen und kaputt gemacht? Ja. Wirklich? Ich noch nie. Wie ist das? Für mich durch den Prozess. Was macht man dann? Also ich bin ein sehr erbauter, ungeschickt Typ. Also mir passieren sehr oft Dinge, wo ich nachher nicht stolz drauf bin. Und es ist passiert, ich denke mal, irgendwie so ein Quark-Ding oder so. Quark, diese Beutel. Ich weiß nicht, wer kauft das eigentlich? So ganz grosse Quarkbehälter, wo so flüssiger Flüssigquark drin ist. Ja, okay, wir reden von Quark. Quark-ähnlicher Quark. Masse, ja. Und dann stehe ich davor, will daneben irgendwie die Mozzarella besorgen. Mozzarella. Mozzarella besorgen. Und dann komme ich halt ungeschickt mit dem linken Ellenbogen, ich habe einen sehr ausladenden linken Ellenbogen, komme ich an die quarkähnliche Quarkform und es fällt der Quark runter und platzt. Und dann ist der ganze Boden vor der Tiefkühlabteilung, ist halt voll. Voll gequarkt, ja. Quark, alles voll quarkähnlicher Substanz und dann gehe ich natürlich weg. Ich gehe schnellen Schrittes weg.
Oh, Hit and Run.
Ich gehe schnellen, das war kein Unerwarteter, aber ich gehe schnellen Schrittes weg.
Lasse meine Waren. nicht ja Substanz. Und dann gehe ich natürlich weg. Ich gehe schnell einen Schrittes weg. Oh, Hit and Run.
Das war kein Unerwarteter, aber ich gehe
schnell einen Schrittes weg, lasse meine Waren,
alle meine Waren fallen in den Quark
und gehe rückwärts wieder raus.
Die Fingerabdrücke ab, ja.
Mit so einem kleinen Pinsel habe ich immer mit
alles, was ich angefasst habe in den Supermarkt,
die ganzen Dijon-Senf-Sorten,
die ich angefasst habe, um zu gucken, was alles
die Unterschiede sind, mache ich alles wieder mit dem Pinsel weg und dann verschwinde ich natürlich. Aber du hast da wirklich keinen Mitarbeiter informiert oder so? Auf gar keinen Fall. Das ist mir viel zu unangenehm. Aber tatsächlich, ich meine, es gibt ja so Klassiker, gerade so Glasgeschichten fallen ja wahrscheinlich oft runter, dann so Milchprodukte und sowas. Aber ich fände die Vorstellung so lustig, dass irgendwas kaputt geht, was eigentlich nicht kaputt gehen sollte, wenn es runterfällt. Irgendwie so eine Cornflakes-Packung oder so fällt runter und ist dann komplett zerstört und überall die Cornflakes und man holt jemanden und der dann so, wie, was ist dir passiert? Ist einfach runtergefallen. Oder du gehst in so ein Glas... Ist gestoßen und runtergefallen. Oder du gehst in so ein Glasfachgeschäft, wo die auch unkaputtbare Gläser gibt es ja, die nicht kaputt gehen, wenn man die runterschmeißt. Ja, Steine
nennt man das, ja. Nein, es gibt wirklich so Gläser,
die sind dafür da, die sind besonders hart
oder so, und wenn man die runterschmeißt,
dann sollen die nicht kaputt gehen.
Und ich glaube, wenn man die im Supermarkt
runterschmeißt, also in diesem Glasfachgeschäft
runterschmeißt und die kaputt gehen,
muss man die nicht bezahlen,
weil die waren ja dann offensichtlich defekt.
Oder? Ist das nicht der erste Schritt, den man dann macht, dass man das Glas runterschmeißt, um zu probieren, ob es funktioniert? Das ist der dümmste Plan, den ich je gehört habe, wer das auch nicht, wo der hinführen soll. Wir gehen da hin, machen Gläser kaputt, um sie nicht bezahlen zu müssen. Nein, also wenn du so ein Glas wirklich vorhast zu kaufen, dann würde ich es erstmal runterschmeissen, weil wenn es kaputt geht, ist es offensichtlich ein Fehlprodukt. Es ist sehr schnell zu testen, ob es ein gutes Produkt ist. Das ist doch perfekt. Du willst einen Kap... Vergiss es einfach, vergiss es. Forget it. Genau hier endet Fulrentins Vorstellungskraft. Bei nicht kaputtbaren Gläsern. Ja, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Glas ist für mich per Definition zerbrechlich. Tja, einfach so. Das ist okay. Mir ist noch nie was runtergefallen und ich bin froh, weil ich sehe das immer bei anderen Leuten, also ständig,
und finde es tatsächlich sehr unangenehm.
Du bringst sie auch dazu, da kommt dann wieder der Prankster raus,
der Leute wie mich, die dann so ganz umständlich die Dinge balancieren,
immer erschreckt.
Ja, und du deine getrockneten Mangos,
so eine Packung getrockneter Mangos fällt runter und explodiert einfach.
Bam!
Und überall sind die getrockneten Mangos.
Und dann kommt so ein ganz saurer Geruch raus, weil diese Dinge niemand kauft und sich zwischendurch so Gase in den Mangos gebildet haben.
Ja, und es ist aufgefallen, dass die meisten Supermärkte links, also die meisten Supermärkte sind so gebaut, dass man links rumgehen muss.
Man muss ständig links rumgehen, und das ist so, weil Menschen von Natur aus links rumgehen.
Also wenn du auf weiter Flur bist und du denkst, du gehst einen geraden Weg, ist es ja eh schwer, einen geraden Weg zu gehen. Und dann geht man meistens so einen links gebogenen Kreis. Menschen sind da wirklich Linksgänger, warum auch immer. Und deswegen sind Supermärkte meistens links rum gebaut, damit man sich als Mensch gut fühlt. Supermärkte versuchen ja in allen Belangen, dass du als Käufer zufrieden bist, da wo du gerade bist. Und bei dir quasi fruchtet das alles. Wenn du sehr gerne in Supermärkten bist, heisst das, du bist sehr anfällig für sowas. Wie sieht es aus mit peinlichen Einkäufen? Bist du da anfällig? Warum bist du da jetzt nicht drauf eingegangen? Genau. Was soll ich dazu sagen? Die Leute gehen gerne linksrum. Ja, wow, toll, da kann man jetzt einen politischen Gag machen, machen wir nicht. Von daher, mehr geht da nicht. Mehr kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Da ändert meine Vorstellungskraft. Okay, aber jetzt wenigstens professionell hättest du mich zum Beispiel nicht im Regen stehen lassen können, sondern jetzt einfach mal eine gute Überleitung machen können, um irgendwie nicht peinlich von dem Thema wegzuleiten.
Aber okay.
Ja, okay.
Ja, ist krass sauinteressant.
So, genau.
Es ist auch immer total viel Psychologie im Spiel bei so Supermärkten.
So die teuren Sachen in der Mitte und wo man eh hinguckt und so und das ist ja alles immer total interessant. Wie sieht es denn bei dir aus mit peinlichen Einkäufen? Bist du da anfällig irgendwie, die klassische Gurke-Kondom-Kombination? Gurke-Kondom und Entschuldigungskarte irgendwie, ist das ein Problem, dann sowas zusammen einzukaufen? Ich gehe sehr selten einkaufen, weil ich dann versuche immer, alles abzudecken und möglichst selten einkaufen zu gehen, weil es halt auch Zeit kostet.
Und dann musste ich neulich, brauchte ich gar nicht viel. Du brauchst eigentlich nur ein Fernglas und ein Willkommen in der Nachbarschaftsgrusskarte, mehr brauchst du nicht. Aber, das ist natürlich schön.
Und dann, und Sagotan, sehr viel Sagotan.
Und dann brauchte ich in der Tat Küchentücher. Also ich wollte, ist hier ein Missgeschick passiert, innerhalb der Wohnung. Und ich brauchte Küchentücher, sehr viele Küchentücher. Und weil ich die nicht hatte, ich hatte keine Tuchformmähige Art des Gegenstandes hier. Man brauchte halt Küchentücher. Eine tuchartige Masse zur Hand, ja. Quark. Ich brauchte einfach sehr viel Küchentücher und Eiswürfel. Da dachte ich mir, wenn ich schon mal da bin, kann ich mir auch Eiswürfel besorgen, weil da war es sehr, sehr, sehr warm zu der Zeit. Und das war so eine Form, wo ich mir dachte, gut, ich brauche Küchentücher, sehr viele Küchentücher gekauft und Eiswürfel. Was genau denken die Leute jetzt von dir, was du machst? Weil ich zum Beispiel, wenn ich Leute sehe, die vor mir an der Kasse sind oder so, dann mache ich mir immer Geschichten, denke ich mir daraus. Was brauchen die? Was braucht der Mann, der gerade den Chantree von der Kasse und die Rasierklinge gekauft hat? Was hat der heute Abend noch vor? Lebt der Mensch morgen noch? Oder will er sich vielleicht umbringen mit den Rasierklingen? Das sind diese Geschichten, die mir in den Kopf kommen. Und deswegen, das war schon peinlich. Ja, oder die andere, also ich war mal lange Zeit in eine Kassiererin verliebt und dann kann man ja auch so ein bisschen Strategien bauen, weil man ja tatsächlich eine ganze Beziehung darüber aufbaut.
Weil man sehr cool wirken will.
Man kann Geschichten erzählen, dadurch was man einkauft. Man kann vermitteln, dass man Single ist, indem man zum Beispiel gar nichts kauft oder kein Geld hat oder weil man immer so für eine Person Sachen kauft. Im Supermarkt geht zum Beispiel niemand raus, ohne was zu kaufen. Und das sind sehr komische Menschen, weil man findet ja immer was. Aber an deiner Stelle hätte ich die XXL-Kondome gekauft und einen guten Zen. Ja, haben sie die extra gross. Was hast du gekauft dann immer, um sie zu beeindrucken? Ich habe immer Zigaretten gekauft, Rum, solche Sachen, Champagner, frisches Bettzeug, Bettbezüge, solche Sachen. Und halt irgendwie so exotische Früchte, irgendwie so eine Drachenfrucht und halt so ein Kochbuch sofort geschützt wird.
Sifalis, Sifalis, Sifalis.
Genau, sowas in der Richtung.
Füsalis.
Einfach um einen guten Eindruck zu machen.
Und tatsächlich kannte ich die aber schon durch einen anderen Bezug, also ich kannte die schon ein bisschen.
Und tatsächlich meine Idee, weil das Thema Supermarkt interessiert mich tatsächlich schon seit langem und ich wollte mal so einen Podcast machen. Nur über Supermärkte. Nur über Supermärkte, ja. Und wo man dann auch zum Beispiel, wo man dann auch einen Kassierer einlädt, dem man dann alle Fragen stellen kann, wie zum Beispiel, was sind diese peinlichen Sachen, die gekauft werden oder was hat es mit Motherfucking-Kassenbon auf sich? So, du kaufst irgendwie eine Packung Kaugummi und die fragt dich, Entschuldigung, sie haben den Kassenbon vergessen. Und du dann nur so, was in alles in der Welt, sollte ich bitte mit diesem Kassenbon... Scheiße, vielen Dank! Boah! Ja, oh, danke, ich hätte nicht gewusst, was ich machen soll. Toll, lieber. Ja, aber sowas hätte ich meine gefragt, ob das denn irgendwie so Firmenpolitik ist, dass man unbedingt das nochmal erwähnen muss, oder wie ist es mit diesen Sammelpunkten, hat man da auch keinen Bock drauf? Und dann war tatsächlich meine Strategie, wie ich diese junge Dame besser kennenlernen konnte, war, einfach mal als random erstes Date lade ich sie in einen Podcast ein. So, hast du nicht Bock, in meinen Podcast zu kommen? Was wahrscheinlich, was ein unglaublich schlechter Move ist irgendwo, aber es hätte mich zumindest immer eine Situation gebracht, wo sie dazu gezwungen ist, eine gewisse Zeit mit mir zu reden. Und dann ist ja kein Problem mehr, wenn ich meine Frau dazu gebracht habe, dass sie gezwungen ist,, mit mir zu reden, hallo, dann ist ja Kinderspiel, ab dann ist ja Dominisch rein nach Dominisch. Dann holst du irgendwann dein Schwert raus und dann ist es vorbei. Genau, dann muss ich ihr nur mein Schwert an der Wand zeigen und sagen so, ab dann hier, ich habe schon frisches Bettzeug und so, und da läuft es dann schon. Und es war tatsächlich die Situation, und ich bin natürlich die klassische Situation, man geht dann immer einkaufen und lässt sich von ihr bedienen und natürlich traut man sich nicht und natürlich man fragt sich auch, was soll das für eine Situation sein, weil es stehen ja auch Leute hinter einem.
Es ist ja so, alle gucken ja an die Person davor. Was kauft sie, wie lange dauert das, er hat das Kleingeld nicht passend, er fragt sie nach dem ersten Date, eigentlich relativ romantisch, aber er ist auch ein ziemlich fucking erbärmlicher Typ, sie überlegt überlegt noch, oh, sie tut so, als müsse sie auf die Uhr schauen, oh, sie macht eine Durchsage, dass die Kasse abge... oh, jetzt hat er keine Antwort bekommen, oh, jetzt geht er raus, jetzt fängt er an zu weinen, oh, er macht die Packung Donuts auf, oh, er macht tatsächlich doch schon die Packung Donuts auf, ist es sein Auto, er setzt sich in sein Auto, oh, noch eine Packung Donuts, er macht jetzt schon die Chips auf, er isst sie in seinem Auto, oh weint, alles voller Tränen. Ungefähr kann das dann ablaufen.
Normaler Tag.
Und es macht natürlich auch für einen die Sache nicht leichter, jemanden auf ein erstes Date einzuladen, wenn halt fünf Leute, fünf erboste Leute hinter einem stehen, die nur darauf warten, dass es schlecht, dass es schnell geht. Und deswegen habe ich es nie gemacht, aber es gab einmal die Situation, ein einziges Mal die Situation, wo tatsächlich gerade der Laden irgendwie zugemacht hat und es hat sich so ein bisschen gelegt und ich war tatsächlich die letzte Person an der Kasse, vor mir zwei Leute und danach hat sich niemand mehr angestellt. Weil du mal genau weißt, dass du den ganzen Tag darin gewartet hast, bis es irgendwann ein bisschen leerer ist und den ganzen Tag in diesem Supermarkt verbracht hast, in einer Senfabteilung.
Und ich dachte mir, jetzt ist meine Chance. So eine Chance kriegst du nie wieder. Jetzt tu es. Und wir kamen ins Gespräch, so ja, hi, was geht, hier, ja, ich muss arbeiten. Vor allem, wie schafft man den Sprung von da, und ich meine, das war irgendwie 2007 oder so, ja, das war jetzt nicht 2015, wo das Podcast Ufo die Charts gestürmt hat und jedes Kind wusste, was ein Podcast ist. Damals war das einfach kein Begriff und man kann nicht jemanden einfach fragen, willst du in meinen Podcast? Was ist ein Podcast? Ja, vor allem, weil du da zwölf warst und bestimmt in deinem Kinderzimmer, irgendwie im Keller, irgendwie so eine Ecke eingerichtet hast, wo so zwei schlechte Mikros, die du irgendwie aus dem Kinderset oder so aus dem Mickey-Maus hast, irgendwie versuchst, da irgendwas aufzunehmen, das ist doch saugruselig, dann auch irgendwie einzuladen dahin, oder? Ja, genau, auf jeden Fall, oh Gott, auf jeden Fall habe ich es tatsächlich über mich gebracht, sie zu fragen, so ja, von wegen, hey, ich habe da so ein Projekt für die Schule und so, halt ein bisschen komplett dumm und so, und wegen, hättest du noch nicht Lust, irgendwie so. Und sie hat erst mal die Reflexe, die Kasse abgeschlossen. Ja, genau, den Notfallknopf, falls jemand in dem Supermarkt immer fällt, einfach sofort an der Kasse unauffällig so däh, däh, däh. Genau, so Gitter kommen so zwischen uns runtergeschockt. Er hat kurz das Mikro genommen, Security, bitte neun.
Kasse neun, bitte Security, Herr Geisler, bitte einmal an Kasse neun. Genau so ist es in der Art, und sie hat dann so halb zugesagt, so ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich da die richtige Person dafür bin und so. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja. Ich weiß nicht, ob jemand die richtige Person dafür ist. Und dann habe ich knallhart souverän gesagt, ja, überlegst dir, ich kann dir ja schon mal die Fragen per E-Mail schicken. Und dann kannst du es entscheiden, dann hat sie mir ihre E-Mail-Adresse gegeben. Und ich habe ihr nie irgendwas geschickt, nie irgendwie geschrieben, weil ich ab dann einfach komplett am Boden zerstört war. Nee, sie war erreichbar. Sie war erreichbar, ja. Sie hat diese Unerreichbarkeits-Kassiererin-Flair sie verloren. Ja, ja, genau. Ja, vor allem sie hat im Grunde Nein gesagt. Und ich habe gesagt so, falls du dich doch noch entscheidest, gib mir deine E-Mail-Adresse, war es wahrscheinlich auch nicht so vom Creepiness-Level her auch nicht so die Beste. Und ich glaube, diese E-Mail-Adresse existiert nicht. Da waren ganz viele seltsame Zeichen drin. Wegwerf.web.de war vielleicht nicht die richtige E-Mail-Adresse. Ach, nein. Ja, genau, irgendwelche Ziffern. Und ja, so ist das Ganze dann geändert. Und tatsächlich ist es mittlerweile so, dass dieser Edeka auch so eine Einstellkultur hat, dass da irgendwie nur Leute aus meinem Freundeskreis eingestellt werden, aus meinem ehemaligen Freundeskreis. Das ist anscheinend da Einstellungsbedingungen, wo man nur eingestellt wird, wenn man mich kennt. Das heißt, ich kann da auch nicht mehr einkaufen gehen. Tatsächlich geht es nicht, weil es zu peinlich ist, irgendw irgendwelche Leute aus der alten Schulzeit irgendwie an der Kasse zu treffen und dann so, ah, du arbeitest an der Kasse bei Edeka, ja, alles, okay, alles da, gut, tschau, mach's gut und so, das ist echt unangenehm, deswegen kann ich da nicht mehr hingehen. Das war die Geschichte von mir und der Kassiererin. Traurig, traurig, aber auf irgendeine Art auch berührend, berührend schön. Ja, aber da habe ich tatsächlich, weil ich kannte die von meinem Zivildienst, die hat ein Praktikum gemacht, wo ich Zivildienst gemacht habe, und da waren wir tatsächlich zusammen Essen, also wir beide und 80 Kinder, was natürlich auch so diese erste Date-Situation ein bisschen anders macht, und da habe ich einen richtig guten Gag gemacht. Damals war ich noch nicht so cool wie heute, aber ich habe einen richtig guten Gag gemacht, auch im Nachhinein, wo ich mir dachte, hey, ich bin gar nicht so zu uns gefallen. Kannst du dir das merken? Echt? Ja, den Gag konnte ich mir merken. Ich weiß nichts mehr von diesem Tag, aber den Gag konnte ich mir merken. Und zwar hatte da irgendein Kind so ein Bilderbuch dabei, so ein Märchenbuch, wo dann irgendwie Prinz und Prinzessin irgendeine Liebesgeschichte, Prinzessin liegt irgendwie im, ich weiß nicht, wie das heißt, aber Prinzessin schläft irgendwie ewig lang, irgendwie chillt ihr Leben und der Prinz rettet sie dann irgendwie von so einem Kobold oder so. Und da habe ich das erste Mal Observational Comedy vom Feinsten angewendet und habe gesagt, ja, Moment mal, in diesen Märchen geht es ja immer um Prinz und Prinzessin, aber sind Prinz und Prinzessin dann nicht eigentlich Geschwister? und das fand sie ganz okay. Und daran kann ich mich noch erinnern. Also nur, also jetzt. Hui, du. Da war ganz schön deep. Da dachte ich mir, da dachte ich, ja, ganz schön deep. Tatsächlich, auch wieder auf die Sexualitätsecke hieven. Sofort das Gespräch in die Ecke lenken. Leider hat es der Satz danach, willst du meine Prinzessin sein, so ein bisschen
in die komische Richtung
gelenkt. Aber da kann nicht dein
Märchenfrosch sein.
Nee.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Du, ganz kurz, ich würde gerne eine neue
Rubrik einführen. Entschuldigung, dass ich jetzt gerade
so einen 20-minütigen Exkurs in die dunklen
Ne, ist voll okay. Ja, freue ich mich drauf.
Freue ich mich drauf. Falls du gerade zuhörst, du weißt, wer gemeint ist, call me. Ich glaube nicht, ich glaube nicht. Ich bezweifle es. Viel zu cool. Sie weiss auch noch nicht, was ein Podcast ist. Ich wollte ganz kurz eine neue Rubrik einführen, einfach mal aus Scheiss. Ist mir aufgefallen was, ich habe ein paar Folgen gehört mal, so von uns, und da ist mir was aufgefallen, deswegen würde ich gerne die Rubrik einführen, das Podcast-Ufo, der Fake-Check. Wo wir im Nachhinein, das hast du auch schon mal gemacht, du hast auch schon mal irgendwie gesagt, ich habe ja mal Partizipial-Verben gesagt, einfach weil es so ein schönes Wort ist, Partizipial-Verben, da hattest du im Nachhinein dann auch gesagt, übrigens vor Folge drei, drei Folgen oder so zuvor, hast du was gesagt, was gar nicht existiert. Und du hast mich einfach in so eine komische Ecke gestellt. Und das würde ich gerne mit dir auch mal machen. Du hast nämlich vor ein paar Folgen behauptet, dass Entenquaken kein Echo hat. Ich habe es natürlich nachgeguckt. Ich wusste, dass dieser Moment irgendwann kommen wird. Okay, ja, komm, hit me, auf geht's. Aber du hast auch damals zu deiner Vertreterin gesagt, du weißt es nicht unbedingt. Ja, das sagt er bei allen Fakten, kann man das einfach danach sagen.
Natürlich hat Entenquaken, hat
natürlich ein Echo. Ja, ja, ich habe auch die
Mythbusters-Folge gesehen, ja, ja.
Aber allerdings ist es glaube ich,
nee, es war nicht Mythbusters,
allerdings hat es so einen, hat es einen komischen
Laut, ist es das, dass man nicht genau weiß,
wo der Laut endet und das Echo
anfängt. Also hat mir irgendwer,
ich weiß nicht, Florentin Will oder so, irgendwann behauptet, dass es kein Echo gibt, aber tatsächlich gibt es ein Echo. Und das wollte ich noch sagen. Und das war die Rubrik. Und das war Fake Check. Weißt du, wenn du solche Rubriken vorschlägst, wenn wir die Sendung planen, und du einfach schreibst Fake Check, weißt du, das sind so Kategorien, da kann man sich nichts darunter vorstellen. So, hey, wollen wir nächste Folge einen Fake Check machen? Was soll das denn sein? Ich dachte, wir machen jetzt so Galileo-Mystery-mässig. Schauen wir uns irgend so ein virales Video an und beschließen, ob es jetzt ein Fake ist oder nicht. Dass das irgendwie dumme Klugscheisserei dahintersteht, wusste ich nicht. Wenn ich das gewusst hätte, hätte ich definitiv diese Rubrik mehr Zeit und Energie. Aber gut, dass du in meinen Nachrichten immer so Dinge hineininterpretierst, anstatt einfach nachzufragen, wie ich das meine. Das war aus rein Notizgründen, habe ich das dir geschrieben, weil ich mir nicht extra eine Notiz anlegen wollte, um dann nachzugucken, oh, was hat das für Ideen für die neue Folge? Ich habe es einfach geschrieben, weil ich dachte, dann hast du es auch irgendwie drin, ich kann den Verlauf nochmal gucken und dann weiß ich, was ich vorgeschlagen habe und das war halt die Idee dahinter.
Und du kannst einfach mal fragen, was es heißt, Stefan, was meinst du denn damit, bestimmte gute Idee, nee, nee, es kommt einfach nicht zurück und in deinem Kämmerchen denkst du dir, was ein Volltrottel, was schlägt der für eine scheisse Idee vor. Mein Auge tut ein bisschen weh.
Ich habe die Befürchtung, ich habe gestern mir grüner Tee gemacht, nicht grün als die Zitrone wie sonst, sondern die herbfrische Variante. Nicht die frisch und spitzige Variante, sondern die herbfrische Variante. Ja. Und dann habe ich in meiner Tasse diesen Beutel gemacht zuerst und habe danach das Wasser reinmachen wollen. Dann ist aber so ein bisschen, hat sich aus dem Teebeutel was gelöst und dann hat sich so quasi Teebeutelinhalt in der Tasse breit gemacht.
Den wollte ich vorher rausmachen, bevor ich das Wasser reinmache, puste rein und das ganze Zeug aus dem Teebeutel geht in mein Auge.
Das heißt, in meinem Auge hat sich grüner Tee herbfrisch gebildet und seitdem tut es wahnsinnig weh.
Und das wollte ich nur mal kurz sagen.
Ist aber gut für die Verdauung. Wenn sich im Auge grüner Tee bildet? Über die Augen, ja. Kann man das am besten einfügen. Gut, dankeschön. Ich mache tatsächlich immer, wollen wir mal Einkaufszettel vergleichen, wer die cooleren Einkaufszettel hat? Ja, können wir machen, aber ich habe keinen. Ach so, ich schreibe mir die immer in meinem iPhone aus, deswegen hab ich die.
Ich lösche die sofort wieder. Mein letzter Einkaufssettel, Pürierstab, Suppenkelle, Gewürze und Messerschärfer. Alter, da hat aber jemand was vor. Oh, da hat aber jemand was vor, du. Das ist ja immer... Das ist ja kinder... Ja, da komme ich, ja, ja, ich sag, ja, ich sag mal so, ich will jetzt nicht die Ladies schon zu stark beeindrucken. Irgendwie, ihr habt es schon genug abbekommen. Für euch wurde genug getan in dieser Folge. Aber ich bin ins Koch-Business eingestiegen. Ja, ja, tatsächlich, ich werde zum Koch. Ja, ich bin tatsächlich mittlerweile auch in der Lage, euch kulinarisch zu verwöhnen. Von daher, beware. Ich finde es nicht gut, dass das Podcast-Ufel mittlerweile so eine Dating-Plattform benutzt. Und dass auch konstant meine Handynummer unten eingeblendet wird. Das irritiert doch einfach. Mein vorletzter Einkaufszentel, Weichspüler, Seife, Milch, Cornflakes, Yogo und Eier. Ich weiß nicht genau, warum ich Yogo geschrieben habe, statt Joghurt, aber einfach mal, um es ein bisschen peppig, frisch, ein bisschen jugendlich zu machen, einfach mal Yogo statt Joghurt. Einfach auch ein bisschen Party zu machen im Supermarkt, ich bin ja irgendwie ein verrückter Typ, dass man da einfach mal ein bisschen drauf eingehielt. Aber geht es dir auch so, dass wenn du an den Kassen stehst, erstens immer an der falschen stehst, weil natürlich während du dich... Ach, jetzt kommen wir doch auf damit, ey! Das ist das die nebeste Observation aller Zeiten! Ich wollte vielleicht gerade in eine gute Richtung einblicken, und dann aber nein, es kommt... Weißt du? Nein! Das war die coole Kassengeschichte, die coole Gestachtskassengescheschichte von heute Morgen kriegst du jetzt nicht zu hören. Aber diese Murphy's Law-Beobachtungen müssen wir jetzt echt nicht darauf eingehen. Das ist wirklich die Observation der Observation-Comedy, wenn man darauf wirklich darauf eingeht. Ist dir schon mal aufgefallen, dass wenn man Brot runterwirft, dass es dann immer auf der Marmeladenseite landet? Das ist ja echt total crazy. Und das ist bei Katzen, egal wie man die runterschmeißt, landen die immer auf den Füssen. Boah, wie crazy wäre es, wenn man ein Marmeladenbrot auf eine Katze tut, dann weiß man nicht, wo die drauf landet. Weißt du, so was haben die Leute vor 30 Jahren geschrieben, solche Gags. Da bist du Stefan Tatzleiter, da bist du wirklich weit von entfernt, so was, da musst du dich nicht, du musst dich nicht auf dieses Niveau begeben. Das ist doch echt wirklich der schlimmste Moment, kennst du den Moment, wenn du Gags machst, die eigentlich schlechter sind als dein normales Niveau, einfach nur um Gags zu machen. Zum Beispiel, wenn du jemanden beeindrucken willst, zum Beispiel, wenn du an der Kasse stehst und irgendwie gerade irgendwie ein schlechter Gag kommt und du siehst gerade, okay, ich muss mit irgendwas arbeiten. Du stehst auf der Bühne, das Publikum gähnt vor dir, du musst mit irgendwas arbeiten. Du guckst dich um und siehst dann diese Kundendifferenzierungsmodule und machst dann den uralten Gag so, was muss man eigentlich machen, wenn man die kaufen will? Weil wenn man sie aufs Aufband stellt, dann... Ja, Entschuldigung, du hast da ein fucking Internetvideo drüber gemacht. Du hast darüber ein Video gemacht. Na, nein, nicht über den... Klar, dein fucking YouTube-Channel, da hast du ein Video drüber gemacht. Fünf Minuten geht es nur darum, dass du jetzt... Nein, aber nicht der Gag. Nur weil es ein Gag ist über ein Kundenfinanzierungsmodul, ist es nicht... Wie man das kauft, wie man das kauft. Hat jemand da gemacht, du hast es auf die Spitze getrieben. Was? Klar! Aber als... Nein, das war nicht der Gag. Nein, fuck it. Nope, no way. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. So nicht, so nicht. Ich gestehe ein, dass ich manchmal echt schlechte Witze mache, wenn ich irgendwie vor einer Frau stehe, die ich beeindrucken will. Gestehe ich ein und ich fühle mich schlecht und ich tue Busse und ich geißle mich mit der Mario-Bart-DVD von seiner ersten Live-Tour. Okay, aber nicht in Sachen, die ich so raushau, irgendwie als Video oder als Tweet oder sowas. Da mache ich nicht solche schlechten Gags, okay? Ich bin kein schlechter Mensch. Ja, sehr gut. Das war die Wutrede. Das ist tatsächlich auch mal... Schön, dass wir uns öffentlich streiten. Das ist tatsächlich, wenn ihr mal einen schlechten Gag von mir hört, dann ist es ein Zeichen, dass ich euch wirklich gerne habe, weil ich dann mir nicht so schade bin, auch die schlechten Gags rauszuhauen, um euch um jeden Preis zu beeindrucken. Das heißt, hört euch jetzt nochmal die Podcast-Rufus an. Und wenn da ein schlechter Gag dabei ist, dann nur um euch zu beeindrucken, weil ich euch wirklich gerne habe. Und das sollte euch verdammt nochmal viel mehr sein und vielleicht auch mehr wert sein als ein guter Gag, was von Herzen kommt. Schlechte Gags kommen von Herzen. Florentin Will hat gerade am 5. Juli behauptet, dass jeder Gag, den er auf Twitter gemacht hat, jemals brilliant ist.
Das hat er gerade zwischen den Zeilen gesagt.
Anscheinend ist dir jeder Follower unfassbar wichtig.
Du hast gerade gesagt, du machst schlechte Gags nur bei Leuten, die dir sehr wichtig sind.
Das ist so, nein, das habe ich so nicht gesagt. Ich sage nur, dass ich hinter solchen Gags eher stehe, als wenn ich den Gag gemacht hätte,
dass es unmöglich ist, Kundenreizierungsmodule zu kaufen.
Wie übrigens, was ich tatsächlich saulustig fand, diese eine Stadt, die irgendwie so ein neues Unternehmen sollte die Müllabfuhr machen und die erste Amtshandlung der neuen Müllabfuhr war, sie haben die ganzen Mülleimer weggeschmissen. Also auch die Mülleimer einfach weggeschmissen und in der ganzen Stadt wurden alle Mülleimer weggeschmissen. Und dann hat irgendjemand so, hey, leider gibt es keine Der Müllarmier, ja die haben wir alle weggeschmissen und in der ganzen Stadt wurden alle Mülleimer weggeschmissen.
Und dann hat irgendjemand so, hey, leider gibt es keine Mülleimer mehr. Ja, die haben wir alle weggeschmissen.
So, was? Das soll ich mir gar nicht so gut vorstellen.
Dann erster Arbeitstag, so Leute, wir machen alles richtig, okay, kein Müll mehr in dieser Stadt.
Wir machen alles richtig, okay, wir müssen guten Eindruck machen, wir schmeissen alles weg.
Und dann schmeissen die Mülleimer und die ganzen Tonnen von den Privatleuten schmeissen die ganze Mülltonnen weg. Geheilt einem das nicht eigentlich? Also ist das nicht sogar, ist das nicht Besitz, den man hat? Aber stell dir das vor, irgendwie so am Bahnhof stehen die mit so einem Schraubenzieher und schrauben die Mülleimer ab, aber völlig naiv und so, das ist ein Mülleimer, das muss weg und schreiben das ab. Grossartig, ich fand das
so lustig. Aber darum geht's jetzt nicht.
Es geht darum,
dass wenn ich solche Gags mache, dann ist es
eher was Emotionales, weil man
will ja auch, dass man über einen gelacht wird und man will ja auch
gute Gags machen, als jetzt auf Twitter,
wo es mir wirklich nur knallhart um die Faves
geht, wo es einfach nur um
die vernunftbegabten
Zurufe des Publikums gibt
und nicht um irgendwelche emotionalen Sachen. Das sind
zwei komplett unterschiedliche Arten von Comedy und
Vielen Dank. geht, wo es einfach nur um die vernunftbegabten Zurufe des Publikums gibt und nicht um irgendwelche emotionalen Sachen. Das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche Arten von Comedy und das Thema hatten wir in der letzten Folge schon, also tut es nicht so, dass es auch ein soziales Lachen gibt, wo man auch mal Gags macht, die nicht so gut sind. Sehr gut. Schön auch noch den Bogen geschlagen zur letzten Folge. Dankeschön, du bist halt ein bisschen aggressiv. War der Fake-Check. Ja, nee, aber das ist ein emotionales Thema. Ich finde, du sollst mal etwas Yoga machen oder so. Irgendwie so eine innere Balance finden. Eine Religion oder so, das wäre mal gut für dich. Statt irgendwie jetzt anfangen zu kochen oder so. Vielleicht ist aber auch Kochen das Richtige. Oder bist du seitdem ein Arschloch? Ja, und ich mache jetzt auch einen Kochkurs. Mit meinem Mitbewohner mache ich einen Kochkurs, weil ich will kochen lernen. Ich versuche aber dabei, entweder nicht zu einem Arschloch zu werden oder zu dem grösstmöglichen Arschloch zu werden, weil das, finde ich, sind die beiden akzeptablen Modi. Was ich nicht leiden kann, sind Leute, die so ein mittleres Arschloch sind. Wenn du ein Arschloch bist, dann wärt ein richtiges Arschloch. Dann wirklich so ein, ja, Kochen ist für mich viel mehr als Nahrungszubereitung. Das ist für für mich der Weg ist das Ziel, ja, und dem ist es auch wichtig, zum Beispiel, welche Musik höre ich beim Kochen, das ist für mich ein multisinnliches Erlebnis, das ist für mich einfach viel mehr, auch die Zutaten zu spüren. Jede Zutat hat ihre eigene Stimme und ist ihre ganz eigene Persönlichkeit. So ein Arschloch will ich werden, so einer will ich werden, oder jemand, der es richtig cool macht und ein richtig cooler Typ. So ein Jamie-Oliver-Typ, der zwischen dennoch einen geilen Spruch raushaut, während er Dinge macht, die unfassbar schwierig sind, die einfach so nebenbei macht, er haut mega die geilen Gags raus, flirte nebenbei mit seiner Assistentin und macht nebenbei das beste Essen der Welt, ohne da auch noch mit dem Wimper zu zucken und man selber kriegt das nie im Leben so hin. So ein Typ kannst du auch werden, aber das glaube ich nicht. Da brauchst du mehr Übung, glaube ich. Aber glaubst du nicht, dass wir, die wir schon alles gesehen haben, aus einer Comedy-Perspektive, dass uns einfach gewisse Lebenserfahrungen verwehrt bleiben, weil wir gewisse Dinge nicht ernst nehmen können? Zum Beispiel der Klassiker, irgendwie ein Typ mit einer Akustikgitarre auf einer Party. Ich habe schon so viele Gags darüber gemacht oder halt so viele Gags geschrieben und mit dieser Idee schon so oft auf eine Comedyart rum freestyled, dass ich das glaube ich gar nicht mehr ernst nehmen könnte. Sind wir da nicht einfach zu zynisch und können einfach die schönen Dinge im Leben nicht mehr wahrnehmen?
Weil man wird ja, da haben wir schon oft drüber gesprochen, ob man Comedy-affin wird, weil man einfach nicht gut drauf ist und einfach weil man keinen Erfolg im Leben hat und weil man einfach die Dinge nicht anders ertragen könnte, als wenn man sie nicht durch eine Comedy-Lupe sehen würde. Aber da ist es sicher auch andersrum, dass diese Comedy-Lupe einen unfähig dazu macht, gewisse Dinge zu genießen. Ja, es kann sein. Ich glaube auch, ich glaube das wirklich, dass man irgendwann abstumpft und manche Dinge einfach nicht mehr als schön wahrnimmt. Das kann man mir schon vorstellen.
Ich könnte auch so romantische,
wenn irgendwie mit einer Frau im Sonnenuntergang
sitzen oder so, könnte ich auch
nicht ernst nehmen, glaube ich.
Ich könnte das einfach nicht ernst nehmen. Wir würden da sitzen
mit einem Picknickkorb und
ausgebreitet so eine karierte Decke
und dann der
Camembert und der Brie-Käse
aus dem Norma
liegen dann da ausgebreitet. Ich könnte das nicht ernst nehmen. Ich würde
in ausgebreitet, so eine karierte Decke und dann der Camembert und der Brie-Käse aus dem Norma liegen dann da ausgebreitet. Ich könnte das nicht ernst nehmen. Ich würde kontinuierlich lachen, weil es so eine kitschige Situation ist. Und ich würde dann auch schnell, ich würde das nicht genießen können, weil ich immer auf dem nächsten Gag suche. Und wenn alles perfekt ist, weil alles so super romantisch ist, dann würde ich wahnsinnig werden, weil kein Gag in der Nähe ist. Ja, und auch weil es irgendwie zu ... Ich hasse perfekte Dinge. Ja, und es ist halt auch so konstruiert in gewisser Weise. Das ist immer so ein bisschen das Problem für mich. Weil da wird es immer absurd. Die Situation ist zu absurd eigentlich. Also zum Beispiel frage ich mich zum Beispiel auch, was es denn ist, was einen Comedian von einem normalen Menschen unterscheidet. Wie schafft man es denn, diese Gabe zu haben, alltägliche Dinge auf eine lustige Art zu sehen? Und das ist natürlich ein bisschen dieses Unvermögen, Dinge für das zu nehmen, was sie sind, sondern einfach immer auch die Backstory dahinter zu erfragen, die Absurdität. Zum Beispiel, wenn ich den Typen auf einer Party sehen würde, der eine Akustikgitarre mitbringt. An sich ist es ja eine total naive Überlegung, so von wegen, hey, ich habe ein unterhaltsames Talent, mit dem ich anderen Menschen Freude machen kann, also nehme ich das in einen Ort, in dem gesellschaftliche Freude erwartet wird, und Party nehme ich mit und alle freuen sich ja im Übrigen. Im Endeffekt ist es ja auch nichts Schlechtes, aber wir, wir fucking zynischen, neidischen Dödel, die einfach nie die Frau abkriegen, sondern der coole Typ, der Gitarre spielt. Nee, das ist auch nicht der. Das ist nie der Typ. Ja, okay, andere Diskussionen hatten wir auch schon mal, dass der Typ, der Gitarre spielt, nie die Frau abkriegt. Das war dann der Punkt, als ich Gitarre gespielt habe. Aber es ist ein anderes Thema. Ja, weil du irgendwie so ganz komische, so klassische Sachen lernst auch. Nee, ich nicht. Ich hatte aber auch schon mal eine Wonderwall-Phase und dann ist es halt klassisch am Lagerfeuer so, du spielst halt Gitarre, Wonderwall, alle Künchen rum, nur du nicht. Kurz nochmal für die nicht musikaffinen, das liegt halt vier Akkorde. Also wie man eine Wonderwall-Phase haben kann, finde ich sehr beeindruckend. Ja, aber die Reihenfolge. Eine Phase, in der man einfach nur vier Akkorde lang spielt, aber die irgendwann sehr gut, die irgendwann sehr gut drauf hat. Eine Phase, die sich über mehrere Monate zieht, einfach gross. Also ich glaube, was den Comedian vom Nicht-Comedian unterscheidet, ist auch eine gewisse Neugier. Ja, ich weiß. Komplexität von Dingen zu müssen. Nein, das ist mich doch am Beispiel. Naja, okay. Ich hätte es am Beispiel festgemacht. Wenn ein normaler Mensch jemand sieht mit einer Akustikgitarre, der auf einer Party auftaucht, dann sagt er, hey, cool, er ist dabei. Ich würde mir Gedanken machen, wie genau hat das stattgefunden? Wann hat er den Entschluss getroffen, die Akustikgitarre mitzunehmen? War er davor schon irgendwo? Wusste er, dass er auf die Party geht? War er davor schon mit Freunden essen? War er vielleicht im Kino, hatte da die Akustikgitarre dabei? Ich rede mich vor allem mal schon auf, wenn ich Leute mit dieser gitarrenförmigen Tasche sehe. Weil ich mir immer denke, wo wollte er jetzt damit hin, um Leuten die nächsten Stunde auf den Sack zu gehen, wo wollte er damit hin und meistens... Aber auch zum Beispiel, wie ist er auf die Party gekommen, ist er alleine gekommen oder wurde er von einem Freund abgeholt und dann fährt der Freund vor seiner Wohnung vor und der Typ kommt raus mit der Gitarre in der Hand und man sagt, wieso, willst du die jetzt mitnehmen und so, ja, ja, warum, ja,, ich wollte ja auch mit auf die Party nehmen. Da gibt es ja schon Probleme. Und dann kommst du auf der Party an und dann der Gastgeber begrüsst dich und dann, wo kann ich meine Gitarre hinstellen? Achso, du hast eine Gitarre dabei. Achso, warum noch gleich? Warum? Und dann auf der Party läuft ja zum Beispiel auch Musik. Das heißt, wenn der Typ dann, also fängt er dann gleich an, Gitarre zu Nein, ich l ich lache dir. Oder nimmt er erstmal an der Party teil und sagt irgendwann Diese mittelförmige, mittelfingerförmige Form der Tasche, sagt er schon aus? Die färbeste Form, ja. Die tragen wie so einen Mittelfinger auf dem Rücken, als Rucksack. Mittelförmigen Rucksack, so einen mittelfingerförmigen Rucksack tragen die. Und er sagt doch nichts anderes aus als Achtung folgendes, deine Party wird an irgendeinem Punkt scheiße werden, die Musik wird mir nicht gefallen, ich werde daraufhin die Musik ausmachen, die Gitarre umschnallen und Lieder singen, die ich für besser halte. Also der beleidet dich ja schon damit. Aber was ist diese Situation? Die Situation, wo er dann tatsächlich die Gitarre holt. Also ich meine, in Filmen, also ich kenne es ja nur aus Filmen, ich war noch nie auf einer echten Party, da ist es dann oft so, dass dann irgendwie die süße Ashley sagt dann, hey, du hast doch eine Gitarre dabei, spiel mal Gitarre, so, hey, spiel uns doch was vor, so irgendwie, wenn die Party so abklingt oder sowas. Aber in Filmen ist es ja immer schon so, dass sie halt mitten in die Situation reinspringen. Man sieht auch Leute beim Essen, man sieht aber nie Leute, wie sie sich hinsetzen und die, wo sie nicht hinbissen. Genau, das ist genau der Unterschied. Deswegen ist so ein Pierce Brosnan, ich weiß nicht, warum der mir jetzt einfällt, so ein wahnsinnig cooler Typ. Pierce Brosnan ist so ein geiler Typ, weil er einfach, du siehst ihn nicht, wie er umständlich mit seiner Jacke im Restaurant romantiert, weil er halt schon da sitzt und diese ganzen peinlichen Dinge, wie man sich hinsetzt und die Frau den Stuhl zurückzieht, unbeholfen, diese ganzen Dinge sieht man ja meistens gar nicht mehr. Man sieht einfach nur, wie er da sitzt und cool da sitzt und schon die Situation halt für sich so hergerichtet hat. In diese Szene springt man ja eher, den Anfang und das Ende bekommt man ja meistens gar nicht mit. Genau, da sitzt ein Drehbuchautor, der hat sich Gedanken gemacht, welches einzelne Wort könnte man noch ausstreichen, was kommt raus, was ist alles nicht cool, wie muss die Szene so straff und so knackig wie möglich sein? Und es gibt eben nicht die Szene Kann man jemand die Musik ausmachen? Paul will Gitarre spielen. Ja, das will ich aber jetzt gerade nicht. Das ist mein Lieblingslied. Ja, ne, mach mal aus. Oder wer sagt denn, macht die Musik aus? Diese Musikthematik ist sowieso sehr interessant auf Partys. Das ist wirklich ein Problem. Musik auf Partys. Und es schneidet alles raus. Musik auf Partys ist, finde ich, auch sehr interessant. Das könnte auch ein eigenes Thema sein für eine Folge eigentlich mal, weil ich habe die Erfahrung gemacht, dass man sich, wenn man auf keinem Partysystem im Keller feiert oder so, ist es nämlich so, dass sehr viele Leute theoretisch die Macht hätten, an den PC, wo die Musik von kommt, hinzugehen und das Lied zu wechseln. Was dann zwangsläufig dazu führt, dass kein Lied zu Ende gespielt wird, weil andauernd Leute da vorstehen, die irgendwie ihr Lied zuerst hören wollen oder so. Und zwischendurch kommt immer noch die Spotify-Werbung, mein persönlicher Favorit. Genau. Er ist jemand, hat jemand Spotify-Premium, irgendjemand, Paul, hast du deine Musik zu lachen? Nein, okay, dann nimm die Gitarre. Ja, genau. Und vor allem dann auch noch die Frage, wie lange spielt derjenige? Wann hört der auf? Sagt irgendjemand mal, okay, jetzt ist genug? Oder sagt er irgendwann, okay, das sind alles so diese Momente, die im Film nicht vorkommen, weil da wird ja dann irgendwann der Bösewicht durch die Tür kommen und würde versuchen, Ashley abzuholen und der Held mit der Gitarre würde sagen, hey, nein, Ashley bleibt hier, sie hat hier gerade Spaß und dann Drama, Drama, Drama und so geht's weiter, weil ich solche Situationen nie einfach ausklingen lassen, aber das, diese ganzen technischen Details, die interessieren mich, die würden mich interessieren und deswegen kann ich diese Situation in dem Moment nicht genießen, weil ich mir immer Gedanken darüber machen würde, wie löst er das jetzt, wie kommt er aus der Situation raus, wie, welche Lieder wählt er aus, spielt er das richtig und das ist alles so, das glaube ich ist so der Unterschied, der normale Mensch genießt das einfach und sagt, oh cool, wir spielen Wonderwall, oh können wir Hallelujah danach machen und wir beiden zynischen Deppen stehen in der Ecke des Raumes und machen irgendwie ein Stand-up-Kommel, die Programme nebenbei, versuchen wir zu bauen.
Und wir wünschen uns Songs, die sie nicht spielen können.
Irgendwie die Songs läufig.
Jetzt spielen wir bitte I Got A Feeling.
Ja gut, das kann man auch spielen.
Mach mal bitte irgendwas Techno.
Was kann man eigentlich? mal bitte irgendwas Techno.
Was kann man eigentlich?
Mach mal irgendwas Techno.
Diese Musik, weißt du?
Ja, uff, uff, uff, genau.
Und stell das dann ins Internet rein.
Vielleicht in dieses Internet.
Weißt du, was in meiner Vorstellung auch oft ein Problem
ist, von Leuten,
die das echte Leben eigentlich nur durch Serien und Filme
kennen, so wie ich, sind Montagen. Und zwar in Filmen und Serien gibt es oft Montagen. Da werden gewisse Zeitabstände als nur gewisse bruchstückhafte repräsentative Symbole angedeutet. Ich weiß, was du meinst. Es sind diese Szenen, wo plötzlich alles gut läuft, wo man gerade irgendwie so am Anfang ist noch des Films, irgendwie so am Ende des ersten Drittels so,
wo gerade alles plötzlich gut läuft, wo er in einer neuen Situation ist und da alles ganz toll ist.
Und um das zu zeigen, dass das ganze Leben von dem Protagonisten gerade toll ist,
zeigt man ganz viele Aspekte des Lebens.
Genau, zum Beispiel.
Wie er da irgendwie Pizzateich ausrollt, dabei läuft dann irgendwie immer eine geile Musik,
also eine richtig tolle Musik, ein Soundtrack des Lebens.
Genau, und dann wie er gerade seine Arbeitsstelle verlässt, er wirft irgendwie die Schürze weg, dann die Situation, er schwingt sich auf sein Fahrrad, dann die Situation, die Tür geht auf und seine Freundin steht davor, dann schnitt irgendwie, sie trinkt ein Bier auf einer Party, jemand spielt Gitarre, aber man schneidet weg, man schneidet weg irgendwie zum See, alle sind an den See gefahren und sie machen Party, aber nirgendwo steht irgendwie, hey Leute, wollen wir zum See fahren? Zu welchem See? Ja, zu dem See. Ah, der ist echt sauber weg. Ne, wir können fahren. Das ist alles rausgeschnitten. Das ist das Problem. Das denke ich mir auch immer, deswegen, wenn ich mir morgens zum Beispiel, wenn ich morgens aus dem Haus gehe und dann habe ich ein geiles Lied angemacht, so ein geiles Sommerhit, so ein geiles Sommerhit, dann denke ich mir auch immer, okay, das ist genau diese Szene, wie du aus der Tür läufst, ist genau die Szene, die auch drankommen würde in so einer Montage, wie jemand aus der Tür läuft und einen geilen Tag beginnt und denke mir, geil, der Moment hält an, der Moment hält an, ich setze die Sonnenbrille auf und laufe los und dann, ich weiß genau, der Moment, die Montage würde genau enden, wie ich an der Ampel stehe und darauf warte, weil meine U-Bahn verpasst und wie so ein behindert, ne, oh, Entschuldigung, wie so ein völliger Vollidiot laufe ich dann in der U-Bahn hinterher. Was war das? Wie so ein völliger Vollidiot. Genau, das kommt nicht in der Montage vor. Oder zum Beispiel, was auch ganz klassisch ist, ist die Suit-Up-Montage, wo man dann irgendwie sieht, wie sich jemand irgendwie einen Anzug anzieht, irgendwie die Krawatte hochzieht, wie man Schötenkämpfe zu knüpft. So ganz was, was aber auch relativ typisch ist, was auch als Montage verwendet wird, sind Dates. Ja, dieses klassische Romantic Comedy irgendwie, der hält irgendwie, man sieht die Szene vielleicht an der Supermarktkasse irgendwie, er ist nervös, irgendwie, er kommt ran und dann sagt sie ja und man hört schon im Hintergrund, geht schon die Musik an, irgendwie so ein Rock'n'Roll Lied, bevor man umschneidet, die Musik lappt schon ein und sie sagt ja und sie lächelt sich zu und dann Schnitt, sie sind auf dem Rummelplatz, man sieht die Zuckerwatte, man sieht irgendwie, sie springen in Pfützen oder sowas, man sieht irgendwie Riesenrad und sowas und dann am Ende irgendwie, sie kommen an, es ist Nacht irgendwie, sie kommen irgendwie vor seinem Haus an und dann geht es wieder in Realtime weiter irgendwie, sie fragen sich gegenseitig, wollt sie noch mit hochkommen und so weiter und so fort. Das Problem ist,
wenn man dann mal in Real Life
auf einem Date ist,
erwartet man auch, dass es irgendwie in der Form als Montage funktioniert, so im Sinne von, okay, gut, ey, cool, sie hat ja gesagt, sie will sich mit mir treffen, okay, da ist sie, okay, jetzt kommt Oh, die Musik kommt, die Musik kommt schon, oh, da kommt die Musik rein, okay, okay. Aber irgendwann merkt man so, nee, das ist nicht so, und dann so, hey, hast du Lust, in die Pfütze zu springen?
Nee, ich habe gerade irgendwie mein Kleid an. Okay. Willst du Zuckerwatte? Ja, okay. Oh, muss nur eine, damit wir beide an der einen Zuckerwasser essen? Nee, ich hätte gerne lieber zwei. Ja, genau. Nee, irgendwie,
ich will keine Zuckerwatte, das bleibt mit meinen Haaren
kleben. Okay. Milchshake!
Wir können uns einen Milchshake teilen mit zwei Strohhalmen.
Nee, ich bin Laktoseintolerant.
Ich bin allergisch. Aber du kannst dir ruhig einen holen,
ne? Okay. Dann steht man
neun Minuten lang für den Milchshake an
und man denkt sich, wo ist die Montage?
Wann kommt der Schnitt? Komm, wir gehen da in das
aufregende Fahrgeschäft. Nee, ich habe Herzinfarkt gehabt vor ein paar Wochen. Ich kann gar nicht in solche Geschäfte gehen. Komm, wir gehen da oben in dieses hohe Riesenrad, wo oben die Luft ein bisschen dünn wird. Nee, ich habe Krebs, das sollte ich vielleicht nicht tun. Und das ist genau der Unterschied zwischen Vorstellung und Real Life. In der Vorstellung beißt man auch einmal von der Zuckerwatte ab und dann ist scheinbar wieder weg. In Real Life muss man die ganze Zuckerwatte essen und merkt, ey, das ist eigentlich nicht so geil irgendwie und dann so, willst du die noch?
Zuckerwatte ist auch so ein Ding.
Und dann kannst du diese Zuckerwatte ja nicht wegwerfen, weil das ist irgendwie so das Symbol eurer Liebe, das Symbol des ersten Zusammenhangs.
Achtung, Achtung, schlechte Observational, Achtung, wieder schlechte Observational-Einstieg in dein Thema Zuckerwatte. Das ist auch so ein Ding, oder? Ja, auch so was, ne? Ja, genau. Man überlasst den Gag dem Zuschauer einfach so. Make your own Gag. Ja, das wollte ich ja eben auch machen, aber du hast leider recht gehabt mit der Kasse. Kassen, ne? Man stellt sich auch immer an die Falsche an, ne? Genau. Aber Leute würden lachen. Leute würden lachen, weil sie das auch schon mal erlebt haben. Ja, weil sie es kennen, ja, aber nicht weil sie gekterweise. Leute sind dumme Fuckfaces, die dann denken, yeah, habe ich auch schon mal erlebt. Aber das ist tatsächlich so das Problem des echten Lebens. Da muss man sich noch was ausdenken. Kann es ganz handelt nicht eine App geben oder so, wo man sowas beschleunigt irgendwie. Auch so dieses klassische romantische Picknick irgendwie. Man denkt, okay, das geht dann irgendwie zack, zack, zack, man packt das zusammen ein, aber es ist dann halt irgendwie dann doch schwieriger und man muss dann noch ewig irgendwie durch die Gegend fahren und man muss dann so, ah, ich habe jetzt eigentlich gar keine Picknickdecke, kann ich auch ein Handtuch mitnehmen so? Ja, genau. Und man dann das grosse Tui-Handtuch ausbreitet, genau auf den Ameisenhaufen. Ja, oder vor allem auch zwei Tage schon davor überlegt man sich, wir können ja auf ein romantisches Picknick gehen. Ich habe nichts. Also ich kaufe mir ein romantisches Picknick-Tuch, ich kaufe mir einen romantischen Picknick-Korb, ich kaufe mir diese ganzen Sachen. Dann stehen die da rum, oh Gott, Stefan, oh kennt ihr das, wenn ihr gerade mit jemandem redet und dann spricht die Skype-Verbindung ab. Oder Skype ist auch so ein Ding, auch so eine Sache, ist echt total nervig. Hängen geblieben, schreibt er mir gerade. Ich weiß nicht, ob das eine Beleidigung sein soll oder sein Statusbericht. Mein Mac hängt, schreibt er. Naja. Wo waren wir gerade? Ach, keine Ahnung. Wir sind von unserem gesteckten Thema Supermärkte abgeschwiffen, abgeschwoffen in Richtung Comedy-Theorie, wo wir dann aber auch, finde ich, diese ganzen Sachen, sollten wir uns die ganzen Fragen, die wir haben, sind Leute, die sich mit Comedy beschäftigen, abgestimmt im sozialen Leben? Haben die überhaupt ein soziales Leben? Wie sind die so drauf? Wie ticken die so eigentlich? Haben die Psychosen alle? Haben die alle komische Persönlichkeitsstörungen? Diese ganzen Fragen, finde ich, sollten wir auf den Humorkongress stellen. Absolut. Nochmal sehr gut. Wow, gut, dass du da nochmal drauf eingegangen bist. Vielen Dank für alle Spenden, die schon angekommen sind bei uns. Es haben tatsächlich Leute gespendet. Das ist kein Scheiß. Es haben wirklich Leute uns Geld gegeben. Wir wir haben circa 40 euro eingenommen kann man sagen habe ich noch gar nicht habe ich noch
gar nicht erzählt wir haben circa 40 euro eingenommen bei paypal da kann man jetzt auch spenden und
ihr könnt quasi den film spenden den wir naja ich glaube ich stabe ein bisschen hoch vielleicht
machen wir einen gopro film vielleicht machen wir einfach eine lange aufnahme für das podcast
aber das finde ich schon stolz sind wir spritkosten mässig schon mal abgedeckt bis ich sag mal
Vielen Dank. machen wir einen GoPro-Film oder so. Geil. Vielleicht machen wir aber einfach eine lange Aufnahme für das Podcast-Ofos. Aber da bin ich schon echt stolz. Das finde ich schon echt geil. Sind wir Spritkostenmässig schon mal abgedeckt bis, ich sag mal, Kassel. Bis Kassel können wir, also zu Not, wenn das nicht klappen sollte mit dem Kongress, können wir schon mal einen geilen Roadtrip irgendwo in so eine geile Stadt in Deutschland machen. Mit 40 Euro kommt man schon weit. McDrive ist auf jeden Fall drin, ja. Aber nur das Happy Meal. Du, ich verstehe dich leider überhaupt gar nicht mehr, also du brichst komplett ab, ich führ nur noch fest. Komplett raus. Von daher ist alles vorbei jetzt hier, es ist unglaublich. Es bricht wirklich alles zusammen gegen Ende. Von daher aber auch wirklich, also erstmal ganz im Ernst, hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass so wirklich Leute uns Geld geben, echtes, hart verdienstes Geld, wir haben ja im Durchschnitt noch sehr junge Hörer, da ist es natürlich auch super krass, dass sie wahrscheinlich von ihrem wenigen Geld uns nicht gewollt. Wir sollten einen hervorheben, der hat nämlich 25 Euro gespendet. Das ist eine ganze Menge. Ich meine, ich habe 15 Euro gespendet. Vielen Dank, du hast 15. Der hat mehr gespendet als du. Und vor allem, warum spendest du da nicht Geld? Also du hast jetzt Geld übergeben. Vielen Dank, Jonas. Jonas kriegt auf jeden Fall nochmal irgendwie ein extra Bonus Ding, wir malen dir ein Bild. Oder nehmen einen extra zehn Minuten Podcast nur für dich auf, nur für Jonas. Oder du kriegst einen sehr, sehr guten Senf vielleicht auch. Das kann auch sein. Oder wir spielen den Lied. Du kriegst einen mittelguten Senf, einen mittelguten Senf vielleicht. Alles klar, ich glaube, bevor hier alles explodiert, technisch gesehen, alles in die Luft fliegt, um uns in die Ohren fliegt, verabschieden wir uns besser.
Das waren Florian und Stefan vom Podcast.
Aber ganz kurz, bevor du auch moderierst, also nur weil Jonas jetzt schon viel gespendet hat, heisst das nicht, dass ihr nicht noch mehr spenden könnt, denn tatsächlich mit dieser ersten mutigen Spende ist das Basler Podcast-UFO-Hörertreffen plus Humorkongress-Extravaganza-Spektakel ein Stück näher gerückt und wird tatsächlich Realität. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das die Art ist, wie man in Basel spricht. Wir werden es rausfinden, wenn wir tatsächlich dort mit eurer Unterstützung und euch dort treffen. Ich freue mich, ich freue mich und bis dahin ist es nicht Prag. Weiter fleissig flattern und haut ein paar gute Gags raus. Haut einfach mal
heute, jeder der Twitter hat, haut einfach
mal die Woche einfach ein paar geile Gags raus mit dem
Hashtag das Podcast UFO. Ich will
mal ein paar geile Gags jetzt. Wirklich heisse
Gags, denkt euch mal was Neues, Eigenes aus.
Einfach mal irgendwie das Gagtakulum,
das Podcast UFO Gagtakulum
einfach mal diese Woche. Ich rufe jetzt einfach mal
diese Woche das Gagtakulum auf. Das ist uncool zu Wort. Lateinische Endungen sind immer so uncool. Gagtakulum, das Podcast-Ufo-Gektakulum, einfach mal diese Woche, ich rufe jetzt einfach mal diese Woche das Gektakulum auf. Uncool zu Wort, so lateinische Endungen sind immer so uncool, ne? Gektakulum, Panoptikum, so uncool alles, wahnsinnig uncool. Macht einfach, macht was cooles, Leute. Es hört doch eh kein Mensch den Podcast bis zu Ende, was wir die letzten zehn Minuten sagen, ist doch eh immer scheißegal. Ehrlich jetzt? Ich höre immer alle Podcasts zu Ende. Ich höre immer nur das Ende eigentlich, weil da die besten Sachen sind. Naja, ich freue mich jetzt unbeobachtet und ziehe mich jetzt auditiv aus.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, haut rein, viel Spaß dabei, bis zum nächsten Mal, macht's gut.